another question that i think is really
fascinating uh it's by john and the
question is
basically what's the deal with research
looking at cognitive benefits of
creatine supplementation um
john mentions he he saw some articles
years ago talking about how exciting and
promising this is uh but hasn't really
heard a lot since
um
there's some interesting ins and outs of
the creatine literature when it comes to
cognitive stuff i think
i do think there's a little bit of bias
uh in the sport nutrition world where
like creatine does really well with
muscle stuff and i think people
there's just this kind of this glow
surrounding creatine where you're like
oh it's so great it's got to be
incredible for bone and it's got to be
incredible for the brain and it's got to
be incredible for every organ system and
every tissue and like you know you can
go through one by one and say okay
there's strong evidence here there's
decent evidence over here and and all
all down the list so i don't want to
sound like i'm like a creatine skeptic
or anything creatine is excellent but
when it comes to the brain stuff uh
there's a little bit more nuance to it
so like
for example when we uh you know
supplement with creatine do a creatine
loading phase or take uh you know a
maintenance dose for you know a month or
two we see pretty appreciable pretty
large increases in
uh muscle creatine saturation it's far
more uh
muted when it comes to brain creatine so
like if you look at the studies where
they give creatine supplements and they
try to increase brain levels uh
i'm going to link a review in the show
notes but at the time that this review
was written i think in 2021 there had
been 12 studies looking at human uh
brain creatine levels after
supplementation
generally speaking uh so so nine of the
twelve showed a significant increase in
brain creatine um and we're talking
about a magnitude of like five to ten
percent i i am intensely curious about
this how are they measuring that
i imagine they're not taking brain
biopsies no i i think they do the uh the
like uh
the
you know how they do like in the muscle
when you can look for like carnosine
content like the the tnmr i think or the
mrs tms no no um
whatever we'll look into there's like
some acronyms it's related to mri yeah
but they can look at particular uh
compounds within different tissues okay
non-invasively so like um with with
creatine and even in the muscle they'll
sometimes use this method it's very
similar to mri i think it's
mrs or nmr i'll have to look it up all
right we're going to look like dumb
asses when this show goes out i mean
it's some
acronym we're not experts in medical
imaging we're not i feel like we threw
out more potential acronyms there than
the average person could so i i feel
good about our performance yeah exactly
um pick three letters go yeah um but
anyway there is a non-invasive way to
quantify this stuff um usually looks
like it goes up maybe five to ten
percent and i'll also note it looks like
there's some pretty decent evidence that
you need a higher dose if you're trying
to move the needle with brain creatine
and the reason i say that is like when
they look at a vegetarian versus an
omnivore when you look at muscle
creatine you can figure out pretty quick
like vegetarians generally have lower
saturation of muscle creatine because
they're getting less in the diet it's
very straightforward if you look at
brain content vegetarian versus omnivore
there is not a noteworthy or detectable
difference so the amount coming in from
like a normal diet is not even really
moving the needle with brain creatine a
lot of that's just getting synthesized
endogenously
you know like i said there is some
evidence that you can move the needle
with supplementation with high doses but
like some of these studies are
suggesting that you might need to do
like
four weeks of a loading dose so you know
muscle loading is like five or seven
days at 20 grams a day some of these
studies are suggesting like 20 grams a
day for a month uh
and i don't even know what the
uh how long you would have to maintain
that 20 gram dose i'm not really certain
uh if you have to do it for four weeks
that sounds more like a maintenance dose
to me yeah um but but i mean i'm not
going to speculate about
how quickly creatine reverts to baseline
in the brain because i have absolutely
never looked at that at that data
one thing i will note though uh
guanadino acetic acid is a creatine
precursor if you're really interested in
cognitive benefits of creatine might be
worth looking into that it is available
as a supplement and it might be better
for increasing uh brain saturation of
creatine so it's kind of like a
citrulline versus arginine type yeah
yeah
there is some reason to believe that uh
taking that precursor might be more
effective uh and there is some some
research to back that up um so anyway
creatine in the brain is it affected by
dietary creatine intake from food
it's not really a big enough fluctuation
to move the needle uh even omnivores
aren't getting that many grams of
creatine in their typical diet
can you move the needle with
supplementation probably but it takes a
pretty high dose when does this actually
matter
the most promising research
showing some kind of benefits related to
cognitive processing or just like
recovery from brain injury it's usually
when there's some pretty noteworthy
stressors that that are actually
challenging the brain uh so we're
talking about uh you know they're
they're there's looking at things like
sleep deprivation uh alzheimer's disease
uh various pathologies influencing the
brain uh of course traumatic
major or mild traumatic brain injury
usually it's in the case of stressors
another one is like sleep deprivation or
hypoxia combined with exercise which is
energetically i think pretty demanding
on the brain uh usually you're going to
see these types of things in stressor
stressful situations for the brain um
so like your average person who's just
taking like five grams a day or they
have like a pre-workout with like three
grams a day and they're like oh this is
doing wonders for my cognition on like a
normal day-to-day basis i'm honest i
mean i'm open to it but i'm pretty
skeptical based on the vibes i get from
the literature it's not something that's
been explored a great deal but
it's it's going to be neutral to to
slightly positive so i'm not trying to
like
uh you know rain on anybody's parade but
you know i i think the biggest
likelihood of benefit comes from really
high dose supplementation
in the context of actual you know
stressful situations to the brain like i
said uh clinical pathologies uh brain
injuries sleep deprivation things like
that
but while i'm on this topic
uh there's one thing that i kind of have
to to mention
there was a thing going around back in
the day where everybody said
oh if you're a vegetarian you have to
take creatine otherwise your brain
simply is not going to work
and
as you can tell from the things i've
said already
that's a weird statement because like
vegetarian versus omnivore brain
creatine levels are very similar so you
might be wondering where that came from
as far as i can tell that was largely
driven by one paper
uh and it was uh a trial where kind of
like the creatine and and like does
creatine make you bald
yeah yeah or does does caffeine make
creatine ineffective concerns yeah
although that one's getting up there
that's got like five papers yeah but i'm
saying like initially yeah just based on
one thing it's weird like the the
supplement with maybe the most research
on it seems like the things people
discuss the most are
maybe the least supported uh aspects in
that entire body of research yeah yeah
but anyway so like with the vegetarian
omnivore thing people are like oh for
the cognitive effects vegetarians very
much need it if you go to the paper that
everybody cites to say that the
only defensible conclusion
is not that
creatine supplementation has a special
effect for cognition and vegetarians
it's that creatine makes omnivores way
dumber and vegetarians are simply immune
to that effect like that is the direct
interpretation of the data do i believe
that absolutely not i think it was a
false positive that caused just a fluky
poor performance in the omnivore group
on the cognitive i think it was like a
memory task or something like that but
yeah so like people said like okay uh
this
for some reason vegetarians who were on
creatine did not suffer this huge drop
off in cognitive performance and that
just got kind of twisted around into
saying creatine has a way more favorable
cognitive effect in vegetarians when
that's just
not at all what the data actually showed
uh so it was kind of like a
misinterpretation
that through a game of telephone really
picked up in the research world and then
got kind of relayed outside of the
research world
so
conclusions here uh
creatine is nice it's it's very very
good for
high intensity exercise performance
there's little glimpses that it does
nice stuff for other systems in the body
other tissues other organ systems
there's you know i'm not trying to be
negative about creatine it's very very
nice the cognitive stuff isn't quite as
supported for like day-to-day use like i
said uh
you know traumatic brain injury various
pathologies impacting the brain maybe
sleep deprivation um you know there are
instances where creatine appears to be
somewhat helpful uh but generally
speaking it takes a pretty high dose uh
so yeah i think that's uh
that's about all i have to say about uh
cognitive aspects of creatine
might be slightly helpful with a normal
dose that's kind of you know that the
standard five grams a day that you take
for exercise might be helpful in some
situations but i i wouldn't uh i
certainly like you know sometimes people
are like you know what i'm not noticing
anything in the gym but i'm afraid to go
off creatine because i don't want to get
dumber yeah i i don't think there's
any evidence to support that type of
approach